this video will be a direct response to
a video I released more than three years
ago called could the division story
actually happen
call it bad timing or perhaps very good
timing on my part but I put this video
out only weeks before all the events
that followed throughout the next couple
of years
a little different to my usual style of
video if you're someone who would prefer
to keep that clear separation between
video games and real life you may want
to click off now otherwise I look
forward to seeing what the comment
section has in store for me
foreign
[Music]
if you haven't seen the video it was a
lot of fun researching and putting it
together and I definitely recommend
checking it out
but summing up as part of my compulsive
need to compare video games to real life
further increasing the immersion I get
from them I wanted to see if what Dr
Gordon Amherst did through creating the
smallpox virus in a lab was actually
possible
long story short it's already been done
albeit to a much smaller scale
in 2017 Canadian researchers were able
to recreate an extinct pox virus using
mail-order DNA
all they needed was a hundred thousand
dollars a virologist and six months of
work
now they actually made horsebox a very
close relative of smallpox but this was
more than likely to be for ethical
reasons what they wanted to show is that
it's more than possible to create a
synthetic version of smallpox or similar
viruses and that the world now just
needs to find the best way of dealing
with this going forward
from here it would be surprisingly
little work for a biochemist of course
to start dicing and sequencing DNA from
other viruses to reduce the incubation
period and increase the mortality rate
part of why I'm making this video is
because at least 90 of the comments
talked about and compared the dollar flu
to well something I apparently still
can't see on YouTube without being
heavily restricted so I'll just switch
out that word for something more
internet friendly
I'm not going to beat around the bush
here there are some vast differences
most notably the dollar flu was created
with the intention of having a 90
mortality rate and while we haven't been
given any details in game around the
actual numbers because you know Society
is pretty screwed right now and counting
bodies is of lower concern than General
survival but based on the extended
literature for example Thomas parrott's
most recent novel compromised it's
looking like Amherst wasn't far off
achieving his goal
super fluffy unicorn kitties however
depending on the source seems to sit
around a one to four percent mortality
rate
but that video wasn't just about how
deadly the dollar flew was and how to
create it it was about how society would
react
the division story was very closely
based on the real world simulation
operation dark winter
summing up their findings we as a
society are drastically unprepared for
such an incident to occur
but it isn't necessarily the biological
attack that would bring down Society but
industrial civilization itself
before the release of the first game
Ubisoft commissioned the French company
betc to create a software tool called
collapse the end of society simulator
this tool would help create the scenario
for the game
you a patient zero all you had to do was
type in your address and the simulator
does the rest
the virus used in the simulator is a
smallpox supervirus used in game with a
seven day incubation period and a
mortality rate of 90 percent
the simulator used open source
information on over 5000 cities on
population densities hospital and bed
numbers connections between cities and
the rest of the world as well as other
real world data
shortly after giving your location
you'll run through the steps of what
it's about to play out
by day four you're starting to feel ill
you visit the hospital and in turn
infect thousands of others
day six the vaccines run out
supermarkets are virtually empty and
fights begin to break out over
whatever's left the government is forced
to declare a state of emergency
day nine over two million are now
infected and the death toll is over four
hundred thousand law enforcement can no
longer contain the riots martial law is
declared in major cities
by day 22 half a billion people have
died with 1.4 billion infected energy
infrastructure communication systems and
Supply chains failed military chains of
command begin to break down
by day 24 the world as we know it has
collapsed
in 2006 the U.S Department of Homeland
Security issued a guide on pandemic
preparedness which warned of the
mounting risk of a worldwide influenza
pandemic and how it possesses numerous
potentially devastating consequences for
critical infrastructure in the United
States
the pandemic will likely reduce
dramatically the number of available
workers in all sectors and significantly
disrupt the movement of people and goods
which will threaten essential services
and operations
State local and tribal jurisdictions
will be overwhelmed and unable to
provide or ensure the provision of
essential Commodities and services
it goes on to state that a pandemic
could also cause significant economic
and security ramifications potentially
including large-scale social unrest due
to fear of infections or concerns about
safety
other consequences are likely to include
International military conflict
increased terrorist activity internal
unrest political and or economic
collapse humanitarian crisis and
dramatic social change
so what does this have to do with super
fluffy unicorn kitties well this is
where the last few years have given us
more to reflect on
while this pandemic was certainly not to
the same caliber of the dollar flew
there are a number of similarities in
how we as a society reacted to it
before anything was even really known
about it there was Widespread Panic I'm
sure that everyone remembers the
potential toilet paper drought where
people were buying enough toilet paper
to last them upwards of 10 years only
furthering the concern for others who
would in turn increase their basket
spent again adding to the problem
now this is a fairly basic and
relatively unimportant example in the
long run but it shows the effect of what
a small amount of panic can Cascade into
there are other more depressing examples
of medications running low due to panic
stockpiling where sufferers of things
like asthma were struggling to get a
hold of the drugs they needed
although there are many many other
examples I could give even just from the
very small country I live in it paints a
pretty clear picture of how we would
have handled things if it was a much
more dangerous virus
again we're talking relatively early on
here without knowing the full extent of
what it was capable of but regardless
protests demonstrations and Strikes
followed around the world against
responses to the pandemic by
governmental bodies
some were driven by financial hardship
resulting from government measures to
contain the virus as well as
restrictions on travel and entertainment
protests have also occurred in
opposition to the restrictions on
people's movements compulsory wearing of
face masks lockdowns vaccinations and
other measures
some protests were driven by
misinformation conspiracy theories fire
right and other extremist groups and
individuals
in order to prevent the spread
governments broaden Health measures at
varying levels of strictness to restrict
the movement of people and transmission
of the virus
in response to these restrictions
protests have been organized around the
world
some protests have criticized
governments for not acting effectively
enough While others have opposed the
preventative measures
according to analysis as part of the
Global Peace Index as of July 2021 there
have been around 50 000 protests linked
to the pandemic worldwide with five
thousand they turned violent
these protests would of course become
super spreader events and with hospitals
already running at maximum capacity this
would only further feed into the problem
uncertainty about the future in the
feeling of lack of control LED to a
growing belief in conspiracy theories
such as that super fluffy unicorn
kitties is a hoax and that governments
have deliberately created the virus
anti-vaxx beliefs including that
vaccinations and restrictions on
citizens movement are a part of a
governmental plot to control people and
that Bill Gates is behind implanting
microchips into people via vaccinations
naturally it needs to be mentioned that
a number of these misinformation
protests have been driven by organizers
with the intention of making money
in saying that if there was a much
higher mortality rate communication
Services would begin to fail and without
the internet the misinformation wouldn't
have been able to spread so far and wide
at such a rapid pace
so I'll win a little off track here what
does this have to do with the division
story
well honestly everything when comparing
the response to how everything played
out with the dollar flew
I see it as the precursor to what could
come this was our test virus
the developed world is only growing with
City centers becoming more and more
densely populated
history has taught us that it's only a
matter of time before something like
this happens again potentially something
far more deadly than we've seen in our
lifetime
so if super fluffy unicorn kitties was a
practice virus how prepared do you think
we are
if people were dying in droves do you
think we'd still have all the riots
evading of rules and conspiracy theories
and I really need to mention the
sanitation workers they'd be there on
the front lines cleaning and sterilizing
infected areas
if the next pandemic escalates to a
level we aren't prepared for how long
before they band together and start
burning down whole neighborhoods
anyway I think I'm going to go restock
my emergency kits I'm not a prepper at
all but maybe those guys are onto
something
thanks for watching and extremist malice
extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]